the uncivil left that is the subject of
tonight's waters words as many of you
know by now White House press secretary
Sarah Sanders and her family were
refused service at red hen restaurant in
Virginia the owner and others not only
kicked them out but followed them to the
neighboring restaurant and confronted
them
the reason Sarah Sanders works for
Donald Trump while most Americans reject
this type of behavior
congressman Maxine Waters encouraged
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this episode has split the Democratic
Party in half establishment Democrats
like Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi
condemned to Maxine Waters but the hard
left wants to get rough they've been
demonizing Donald Trump and his
supporters for two years the voter you
not Donald Trump are standing at the
ball at border like Nazis going you hear
you hear and I think we now have to flip
it and it's a given the evilness of
Donald Trump if you hold down the woman
while the rapist is raping her and you
didn't rape her are you a rapist tens of
millions of people voted for him after
he showed his cards four years later you
said we are you suggesting that they're
racist or they're yes the people who
vote all the people who voted for Donald
Trump yes
if Republicans weren't so racist they
could encourage black people who are
morally conservative to be on their side
those people who are supporting what he
is doing here are racist period its
movements and people that are speaking
up for things whether we're talking
about civil rights movement whatever
else those movements should be
nonviolent but they should not be non
confrontational they're essentially
saying that if you support Donald Trump
you're an evil racist in their minds
this justifies their uncivil behavior
but left-wing incivility has been around
for Donald Trump and around for a while
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh even Fox News Channel has felt the
heat they don't even know what I did I
[Applause]
was getting the business from a teacher
yesterday there he goes he wants to shut
down the communication my teacher was
giving me the business yesterday and the
teacher told me she hates me because it
makes her feel good the bottom line is
everyone should be treated with respect
in this country Fox News should be CNN
if you like Trump if you like Hillary
we're all Americans and if you want to
change the country just vote